this isn't
a negative it's just
to be expected the studio would bring in
other writers
so 3000 was initially in a kind of a
one-room
scenario maybe a hotel room it was in a
hotel
um very simple locations
um
you know it it's all a little bit of a
jumble if i had to go back and parse
what was this piece there or that piece
there but fundamentally the bulk of the
the bulk of the original story took
place in
a very limited environment you know
there was a car there was a street that
was a hotel it was not
extravagant
and so once it went to the one producer
or the the head of the studios they said
can you lighten it up on a disney scale
this is a four we need a seven
and so then you added these side
characters and maybe well the characters
most of the characters were there there
was the hotel manager there was kit the
best friend there was an elevator you
know a lot of the
a lot of the infrastructure if you will
was there but it did get expanded there
wasn't a big party scene perhaps there
wasn't you know there were certain
things that didn't exist
uh um or that we're dressed up shall we
say
um
you know i don't i don't remember that
we had quite so
showy um a sequence on rodeo drive
that sort of thing
um so yeah it it it definitely evolved
um the beautiful thing was
you know my my my job was clearly to
discover and and launch and protect
great young writers
and i knew that
when we were
having that conversation with disney
um that it was really imperative so the
only the only condition i really had was
uh not about story
it was really about protecting jonathan
and the condition that we put on it was
he has to be guaranteed the first
rewrite
because i had such faith in him that he
would break the back of this and turn it
exactly into the proper you know that
like the best version of its comedic
self
um
knowing the the and this isn't
a negative it's just
to be expected the studio would bring in
other writers
um jonathan had no
never been produced he wasn't well known
and so
he committed the first rewrite we
delivered the first rewrite and long
before it was delivered i was getting
calls from agents saying gary you know
they're reaching out to us for our
clients for you know potent potentially
hiring our clients for
to do a rewrite and i said i know it's
okay thank you for letting me know but
it's absolutely
you know to be expected
and they did there were three other
writers who came in
and um
the first one i i won't mention the name
because i was not a fan of the work at
all it was
unnecessarily
um
it was actually surprisingly dark and
i wasn't a fan of the writing
but they brought in another writer bob
garland who was from the electric
horsemen wonderful new york-based writer
and he polished up all the business
dialogue that was sort of his mission
and the final writer barbara benedict
who was a beloved and you know very
sought after script doctor
came in and did the final
rewrite
and i would describe her work as
bringing it back as close as possible to
the rewrite jonathan had delivered to
the studio sort of brought it full
circle
um
yeah we were very we're very fortunate
this the you know the integrity of the
script was in full tact
uh there was a fair amount of
you know gary marshall is
he had that gene that magical gene
of
finding the heart of everything that
he
i mean his legacy is so profound both in
on the big and small screen right he
just had that gift and um so our our
arrangement with him was yes we're
shifting this from a drama to a comedy
but you know we're doing it quickly and
we're moving and
so once one take is scripted and then
improv and
which was consistent with his style he
gave his amazing director to watch you
learn a lot watching gary marsha what
when i got to watch him work
um he gave enormous freedom
to everyone on the set not just the
talent
he invited participation at every
conceivable level
he gave actors the freedom to riff and
um
and and you know find the moment
and
you know lean into it if you will
so it was it was an extraordinary
the set was a really really exciting
place it was a small small budget by
studio standards we were way way down
that register
um and there was a lot of freedom
because a we had gary marshall b we were
such a small budget they weren't paying
the kind of attention that they do to
some of the bigger films
um but it was a it was a truly wonderful
time
so that one connection at the sundance
lab
kind of led to
it how did you how did it's forgive me
i'm sorry her name one more time
michelle satter michelle satter okay
sorry about that um how did you know
michelle
i'm not sure how i originally met
michelle it might have been through some
of her staff for being at sundance i
used to go every year to the in the
early years to the sundance film
festival
so i don't really my memory doesn't
stretch back that far
but uh michelle was someone that as soon
as i met her i just recognized this is a
wonderful person and really frightfully
smart
and
um and and i've always been incredibly
grateful because you know in fairness
sundance did i i don't think they really
got the proper public acknowledgement
for the role that they played in the
evolution or development and the
possibility of that particular film
interesting but it was but it was a key
moment certainly it brought it it
brought it to the forefront of people's
attention
what were some of the lowest moments you
faced
trying to get pretty woman made or 3 000
made at whatever evolution it was at oh
gosh it every film has its um peaks and
valleys sometimes the valleys outnumber
the peaks
or so it seems at the time
if i look back and think
from the time i held a first draft
script in my hand at the time we were
actually
shooting a film
it was only three years
and in the timeline of many films that's
not very long it's actually quite
wonderful um
but during that time there were moments
when it seemed you know when vestron
declared they were going into bankruptcy
uh that was uh uh you know there was a
lot of strain because if the script was
if we didn't get a turnaround on it if
we didn't actually paper and buy out the
script
uh get it back it would have been buried
forever
that's what happens when you go into
bankruptcy right it gets locked up
so there was a lot of i was i was really
concerned about the project at that
point
um that when we optioned it to new
regency i wouldn't say there was a low
point there was a frustration
not anyone's fault but it's not always
easy to put films together and get them
on track toward production so
it got stalled
and
so that would be more frustr frustrating
over a sustained period of time than it
was upsetting
or a low va you know a low point
um
richard
i was so convinced that richard was
right for this
that when he said no to the project
which happened as i recall both at
vestron and then when we were for some
reason i had this crazy idea that when
we were at new regency we should offer
it again
new environment
uh but same reaction
um
and i understood it richard's a
wonderful you know super educated
professional great i mean he's
fabulous
um but he is a sophisticated and he has
a
a different taste you know being
the guy in a romantic comedy wasn't
necessarily the high point of his
you know
on his wish list it was
almost contrary to the things that he
was most attracted to edgy darker more
sophisticated projects
so there was no surprise there
the surprise was that he we we
eventually succeeded in getting him
but i would say um
another low point might have been when
we first
were setting that we set it up at disney
and i saw all of the people cycling
through perhaps the lowest point for me
i should have been the happiest because
i had a major studio i had a major
director i was like oh my gosh we have
succeeded and yet
i had a really strong inkling about what
this project wanted to become and the
casting that was necessary to get there
and to me the cast was julia and richard
um
and i didn't have to be 100 right about
that but but it's a sliding scale
there's a sort of palette of colors if
you will
and as i was watching all these other
actresses and actors come through
some of them were just meetings because
they were too big to audition they were
just big names there were meetings they
were auditions
some were screen tests
and as i watched some of these
meetings and auditions and certainly the
screen tests i felt my it was like my
heart hurt i had my heart set
i just i trusted my gut i've always
trusted my gut on casting
and it's not that i'm right it's just a
gut
i knew what the film could be with
richard and julia
and if i couldn't have one or the other
or both
we'd do the very next best thing but
when i saw some of these screen tests
and auditions and they were so the far
side
of
dare i say the vision that i had for it
or that jonathan and i had for it
there were moments when i felt i was
seeing the premature death of my film of
the film
and and i couldn't help but feel
anxious and sad and like we we've we've
got to find a solution here
again the god smiled we got our dream
cast and it all worked out
i think i think part of the lesson there
is you really have to know
when and how to speak to an issue and
speak up to the right people at the
right time
and really
try and influence
the outcome
and then when the film hit theaters
how surprised or not surprised were you
with the crowd's reception
well it's always a surprise
you know people always say did you know
it was a hit
the answer is no of course not we were
actually our reputation when we were
shooting was oh that little film in
trouble
uh we were again a very small batch by
studio standards we were turning it from
a comedy from a drama to a comedy
we were it was known that gary marshall
god bless him was going to be doing a
lot of improv so
it wasn't like there was oh my gosh that
film is going to be amazing no we were
like almost more like an experiment than
a film in many people's eyes
[Music]
we did a number i forget the number we
did a few test screenings in outlying
areas of la
and held focus groups afterward
and
with each successive screen test
the first one or two were like okay okay
that's good but i'm nervous
um but as we got audience reaction in
what was working and what they loved
about it and we kept throwing more humor
into it
um the the reactions where you know
you're standing in the back of the
theater at darken theater and you've got
a full theater
and you're you're you're just
on pins and needles waiting to see are
they going to laugh in the right place
are they going to laugh in the wrong
places are they going to understand
what's going on are they what's the word
of mouth as they exit the theater
and you're watching their body language
literally are they
sitting up you know
and
the latter test certainly by the last
test screen but i'd say the last couple
of test screenings
the audience was you couldn't have asked
for a better reaction
at that point i wouldn't say oh my gosh
we have a hit no we were hopeful we were
going to live
because the patients are going to live
when it came out and did the business
that it did which was back then in 1990
march of 1990 we came out and it did
like 11 million and changed the first
weekend
that was a wow
the fact that it went up a little bit
like 12 million the second week that
told us
oh gosh
we have the best thing in the world
going for us word of mouth
people love it and they're talking about
it
um
and i don't remember precisely but that
film lived actively in theaters i was
it's at least half a year
i think it was actually slightly longer
which of course would never happen today
even back then it was an anomaly to have
a a an active theater presence for that
duration but
um
i think even more surprising than that
looking back is it's over 30 years later
31 years later
and it's finding new generations of
audience around the globe
it is a film that you
it's like a machine that just keeps
churning out joy
right and
so to be associated with something like
that is really uh quite phenomenal it's
a blessing and
who could have guessed at that
for all of the
reviews positive was there any criticism
of the film
of the subject matter
i was
i don't recall that there was any
negative um there might have been
but i can't i can't recall that what i
do remember
was on the eve of releasing that film
the thing that had
i don't think i was alone in this
there was a certain nervousness
about putting a film out into the world
where the role you know this lead
character is a working girl and she's
young
when i met julia she was 18
when we shot the film she
was 21 or so
um
and she was a very youthful energy right
so she was this here's this young
beautiful girl
who's a
working girl
um
and as much as we tried to paint the
right version of that picture
carefully
i was really concerned because it was a
time of great feminism
the glorious steinems of the world were
you know
on the front pages
and i thought we were going to get
pilloried i thought there was a good
chance that there would be a lot of
pushback that people would be upset with
us
how dare you
uh and to my great
surprise
that never
it never came to be
those very people that i was most
nervous about embraced it
um so i was actually even more than the
critics i was concerned about some big
public figures who
were leading the feminist movement at
the time and
we might have stepped on
you know we might have hit the wrong
chord here
uh but again that
the thing that really un was underlying
this story i mean it's pygmalion it's
cinderella it's a
it's eternal
right it's a dreamscape
and it's a beautiful love story and
so much so that it that that i guess it
overrides
whatever
sort of socio-political instincts of the
moment might be
present
but yeah no the embrace was
i i i might have selective memory
but the embrace seemed fairly complete
if it had been released now let's
suppose have been made in
2020 2019
pre-pandemic
do you think it would have received the
same
a claim would there have been would
there have been people that had issue
with certain things that i think i think
not
okay um
it's very hard to say what might have
been
uh in some ways i think the original
story might have been better received in
the 2020s than
than the version we made
but i don't know i don't know i mean i
think there's something as i said i
think there's something
predictably eternal about
our love of story and the way we react
to story in certain archetypes
um and certainly romance in general
so i don't know but i think i think that
we live in a time
when people are certainly more critical
and that film might not have fared the
same